you know and i was like oh my gosh so i
was i literally paused the movie got up
and walked out because i was just
bawling
yeah
would you say good writing demands
emotional honesty oh gosh yeah
definitely good writing definitely
demands emotional honesty i think that's
the only way to buy for the audience to
buy in is when we feel the emotion um
it's all about that like literally
that's what it's all about and i would
say the same thing with good directing
as well you know when it see a scene
works
when we feel that emotion and when we
feel like it's authentic
we can tell
when things are just being done or said
or being preached to
and it's not does it feel authentic like
like like we can learn
we can learn lessons
and
and and be told things
in a non-preachy kind of way
um
that feels real
that feels authentic you know a really
good example i think of that is
it
which actually was interesting because
it just got voted the number one
screenplay
of the
what was it of the decade or the 21st
century
um get out
you know when you when you look at get
out and i've and i've read the script
a couple of times and i've watched the
movie a couple times i even watch
you know the the other
ending how how the original ending of
how he how he wanted it to end which was
on a downer actually those that have
seen it before they know how it ends and
and the way it ends now but
that actually is a movie
that
is telling the story about
racism
it's telling a story about
you know
historical injustice
um
and a lot of other things that are being
said there but you don't feel like
you're being preached to
i think that's why it worked
and that's why
people of various
melanin shades went to go see it
because it didn't feel that way even
though we got it it didn't feel that way
and i think that's the big difference
in
how stories are being told it was an
emotional story
but you didn't feel like you were being
preached to
so it always comes down to emotional
integrity for any
any script any scene
and and if you're able to hit that you
know
this is us you know people cry on that
on that show all the time because we
feel what those with those uh characters
are feeling and it feels organic it
doesn't feel like it's it's forced and i
think that's why it works
how hard is it to write an emotional
scene
oh wow
um
i think it depends on how invested you
are in that in that scene like i've
written scenes that i uh
when i wrote it i cried
so
if you're all in
i think you can do it and do it well
and the words and the feeling just flow
you know it's interesting it's like
whatever whenever i'm writing a scene i
think about how do i want people to feel
so
if i know how i want them to feel it
helps to dictate what i'm going to say
or what the characters are going to say
to to get people to feel that way so
it's almost like i i start from the
emotion first
and then
use that as as leverage to to write um
what the characters are going to say
whenever i've done it the other way
around usually the scene doesn't read
on the page the way i attended to to
read
if i start with just the words and like
okay you know
a cheat would be something like you know
um
you know sarah says something and then
i'll put in you know she cries
like that's a cheat
why does she cry if you
go backwards and you know kind of
re-engineer it
what caused her to cry
what is it
you know and that's when you're like
okay yeah what exactly is making her cry
okay what's the feeling that she's
feeling right now she's down because
she's thinking about her father okay
well what's making her thinking about
her father oh why don't i put a picture
in here
you know or do something that helps the
actor or the actress
get to that point you know it's like you
know the saying is you you know is it
earned
is it earned and there's a lot of actors
and actresses who you put down she cries
on the page and they can cry like that
but is it earned like how do you feel as
the audience like do you feel like
crying or is it just that you know
they're really good at their job so
you know they cry and i think that's a
difference
so
yeah
whenever i start from a place of emotion
then i find the right words and or
actions because sometimes the you know
the right words it's just about what are
they doing
you know that
makes them cry
and is it earned and that's a question
that kind of goes back to the michael
jackson situation is this the best that
i that that it can be
you know to me is it earned is the same
thing
you know
do we get them to that point where they
really do need to cry and is it earned
can you give us an example of a film
where that really works
like just a scene that when you watched
it
yeah you knew you wanted to write scenes
that um i know some one person i know
said ordinary people that was just a
movie for them that just just really hit
home
you know for me so
i am actually i'm a big crybaby now
but i was when i was younger
and there was
there was a scene in um life is
beautiful
which to me is my favorite film and at
the time i was a young father i was
married and my son was probably
three years old around there
and so there was a scene
where
the
you know they're in france the germans
are around and he is
you know he does this salute to his son
his son copies it and then he's
explaining to his son like this is all
the game you know can you go hide and
you know i'm gonna you know pretend and
make sure that that that nobody can find
you something like that
and i'm crying my eyes out
because i know
that that is exactly something i would
do with my son
if we were occupied by some hostile
country
i would
make it into a game to try to hide it
the the nuances of this is that he was
hiding what the truth was by making it
to a game
and that's exactly what i would do
and i was like oh my god this is
brilliant and i was just crying and that
let me go back
i was caught up in the emotion i wasn't
thinking about brilliance because at the
time i wasn't breaking down movies
because you know this is way before i
was still a dancer at the time i wasn't
but i knew how i felt about that moment
because that's what i would do as a
father and so
you know
that emotion that that
behavior
is is and he wasn't crying it wasn't it
wasn't an emotional scene in the sense
of like there were tears it was an
emotional scene because
of his behavior his actions
and what he was trying to do to spare
his son you know the possibility of
being called by the nazis and killed
because they were both jewish
you know and i was like oh my gosh so i
was i literally paused the movie got up
and walked out because i was just
bawling